merci monsieur le Président donc depuis
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi sur les
violences au sein de la famille fin 2019
la pension de réversion n'est pas due
dans le cas où le conjoint survivant est
où a été condamné pour avoir commis des
violences conjugales à l'encontre de
l'époux assuré l'amendement que je vous
présente s'inscrit dans le prolongement
de ces dispositions il prévoit de priver
un parent condamné pour violence et
maltraitance à l'encontre de son ou de
ses enfants de l'ensemble des
majorations aux bonifications liées aux
enfants un enfant est tué par l'un de
ses parents tous les 5 jours en France
en moyenne 45% des Français suspectent
au moins un cas de maltraitance dans
leur environnement immédiat famille
voisin collègue amis proches et les
parents représentent 86% des auteurs
présumés de maltraitance donc l'objectif
de cet amendement c'est une mesure de
bon sens en réalité donc et ils vise à
priver le parent maltraitant je vous
remercie
si chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur
écoutez merci d'avoir proposé cette
amendement ces quelques même un problème
tout à fait significatif et il faut que
ces mesures puissent s'appliquer en
complément donc bien sûr nous avons
donné un avis favorable merci
merci monsieur le Président je
souhaitais remercier madame la sénatrice
billon que je cherche à vous remercier
madame la sénatrice parce que nous
avions eu ces échanges autour de cette
piste là et nous craignons dans un
premier temps que cela puisse être
qu'une peine complémentaire décidait par
le juge dans le cadre d'une sanction
mais la rédaction que vous proposez
permet effectivement de donner suite à
ce projet donc la vie est favorable
puisque cela permettra pour des parents
condamnés par un juge pour des faits des
crimes et des délits de maltraitance de
violence sur leurs enfants d'être privé
à la fois des trimestres de majoration
les trimestres d'accueil de l'enfant
d'éducation mais aussi de la prime de la
majoration de 10% dans le cas où ils
auraient trois enfants donc favorable
merci donc je mets au voilà maintenant 6
avec deux amis favorables qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
il est adopté le 4568 madame la
Présidente rossignol
[Musique]